up to this point you've been talking
about real numbers and real numbers are
like pretty much everything you've been
working with you know you learned about
rational numbers and irrational numbers
rational numbers you can write as a
ratio like a fraction irrational numbers
those are like your square roots that
you can't simplify and then you know
integers you know this is like a
subgroup of rational numbers these are
basically positive negative you know
whole number like that and and on and on
so these different subgroups of numbers
okay and what we're actually doing is
we're going up one step here okay to the
complex numbers and complex numbers are
actually part real and part imaginary
and that's what we're gonna be talking
about today is the imaginary component
and basically what an imaginary number
is it's a way of dealing up with the
situation where you have the square root
of a negative number so like say I had
the square root of negative 16 when we
take the square root like say for
example we just take the square root of
25 this is asking us what number times
itself is 25 right so we say well 5
times 5 so the answer is the square root
of 25 is 5 but let me ask you this what
number times itself is negative 16 well
students will sometimes say well
couldn't we do negative 4 times positive
4 that's negative 16 ah but they're not
the same number right so if we do
negative 4 times negative 4 that's
actually positive 16 so that doesn't
work
positive 4 times positive 4 that's also
positive 16 that doesn't work so what
are we going to do about the square root
of a negative 16 that's where I comes in
ok the letter I that's used to denote
imaginary numbers so I is an imaginary
number and it represents the square root
of negative 1 so what we can do is we
can say all right instead of square root
of negative 16 let's write this as
negative 1 times the square root of 16
square root of negative 1 we're just
gonna write this in a condensed way by
using the letter I that denotes square
root of negative 1 and then the square
root of 16 we know that that's just 4 so
we write this as 4i okay so the eye is
just representing this kind of messy
square root of negative 1 kind of thing
and we write it a little bit more
simplified almost like a variable right
for I and so again this is just
representing how to simplify square
roots of negative numbers I'll show you
a couple other examples and I'll also
have a link you know up in the card
section showing you all about complex
numbers how you add them subtract them
multiply them divide them and just one
other note along that same lines is that
you know up to this point you've been
saying two for example but you could
think of it as two plus 0i two real plus
0 imaginary now zero times anything is
zero so we don't mention the 0i we just
mentioned the two right but this is part
of a larger okay group of complex
numbers part real part imaginary let's
look at another example
let's say you have the square root of
negative 100 so same thing square root
of 100 we know it's just 10 right 10
times 10 is 100 but that negative part
okay we can write this as square root of
negative 1 times square root of 100
square root of 100 is 10 the square root
of negative 1 is I and we usually put
the number in front of the eye to the
left of the eye and so this would just
be 10 I so I hope this you know solved
your mystery about what imaginary
numbers are again if you want to learn
more check out the the link I have for
what I talked about in the other video
on complex numbers how to add subtract
multiply and divide them subscribe to
the channel check out some of my other
videos and I'll see you in the future
ones I'll talk to you soon